so plans for the future
does he want kids
of course he does and it's it's his
tradition it's called orchid
hail no
i did all that um isn't that gonna be an
issue then um i can't have them
so just say
we got married just say
i would allow him to marry a second wife
and have kids
i don't want any more kids does usement
want kids absolutely
if usement has multiple wives i feel
like that it's okay because i love him
it's his culture and i respect his
culture and his religion so much i truly
mean that i truly mean that i know it
sounds crazy it's a culture it's a
cultural thing it's not like a threesome
so it doesn't bother your own
relationship and you would have yourself
until you're actually in it but i guess
i wouldn't know until i'm in it you know
i really can't like
i mean we've we've discussed it and when
i actually told him this he was like wow
you're amazing and he was like because
i'm i am you're letting him have two
women but um why hasn't always got to be
so defensive though like can you guys be
happy for me that's how i feel
like i want some happiness in this for
me
and i feel like
everything's so defensive and i have to
be so defensive and this is like my
thing and i'm going and i want to feel
good about it i need to walk away
[Music]